كيف كلفك صدام حسين باجراء اتصالات هل هو
تكليف منه باجراء اتصالات مع المسؤولين
والقاده العرب او كانت مبادره منك
او منهم
باحد اللقاءات اخبرني انه يعني كاتب رساله
ويطلب مني ايصالها الزعيم عربي كان على
علاقه وطيده مع الرئيس يعني اثناء الحكم
وهذا الزعيم العربي يحمل من صفات العروبيه
والشهامه العربيه ما يعني يعجز عن الوصف
[موسيقى]
مشكله هناك كيف اطلع رساله يعني كيف اخذها
فعمليه اخراج الرساله
بطريقه معقده يعني الطريقه لازم تجانب
الامريكي يعني حذر جدا عندما امد ايدي
بجيبي وحذر جدا اذا اسحب اي ورقه استلمها
من رئيس مباشره
فبططريقه الماما اريد اذكرها حصلت على
الرساله
يعني بالطريقه نعرف كيف يعني على الاقل
كان كنا نلتقي اني الرئيس بقياده قوات
الماليز قياده قوات الماريز هذا مقر لقاده
الجيش الامريكي ومقر ايضا للسجن كبار
قاعده النظام الوطني
عمليا عدل القاع اللي احنا فيها البقيه
الاماكن ما مراقبه فيروح الرئيس يعني يعني
يطلب
الذهاب الى الحمام اثناء السير يعني
بالممر يقدر يمد ايده على يعني جيبته
ويلتقط الرساله ويغطيها بمحارم فمن يغطيهم
محارم يبقى يستعملها يمسح بها وجهها
ويخليها على الطاوله اللي احنا قريبين
اقوم انا يعني تقطيع يعني عدد من
هاي المحارم ووضعها بيني وبين الرئيس حتى
اغطي على الاولى فمن اسحبها خليها فوق
الاجنده لانه ما اقدر لا اخليها بالاجنده
او بين اوراقي ولا اخليها لان يراقبونا
الامريكان من مكان متقابلين من نوافذ
زجاجيه ضباط يراقبوننا
ناهيك عن الرقابه الالكترونيه اللي اكيد
احنا محتسبينها
بهاي الطريقه احمل الرسائل القادم
[موسيقى]
شو كان في حواها فحواها بالبدايه يعني
سلام وعتب على هذا القائد انه يفترض يعني
من حق الكبير على اهله هم اللي يسالون
عليه لكن انا اتجاوز الظروف المحيطه به كل
المحيطه بالعالم العربي واني اسلم عليك
يعني بادرت من عندي انه تستخدمون علاقتكم
مع الجانب الامريكي لحقت دماء الشعب
العراقي ولحقن دماء اصدقائكم الامريكان
وراح تكون المبادره مقبوله منك كون يعني
ثقلك العربي وفق لك بالعلاقات الامريكيه
احنا ننتصر بالاخير وانا ما اطلب منك
النجده لنجده رقب رقبه صدام حسين وانما
اطلب من عندك حقن الدماء
اوصلت الرساله وقابلت ذلك القائد العربي
ورحب بي ترحيب واستقبال طيب
وحملني رساله الى الرئيس صدام حسين
[موسيقى]